Thomas
um looking at the screen at one hour six
minutes this is the left hand side if
you can clear your screen right now one
hour six minutes uh since launch or one
hour five I think it is it's very small
25 seconds to the drop we're told now we
were told two cameras one looking at the
rocket one on the rocket itself they
haven't switched those to us yet
no we we can hope and certainly they've
managed to do it for previous launches
and it is they are spectacular uh
pictures as the rocket uh races away
from cosmic girl uh of course it's very
dark uh and that may reduce the
visibility somewhat but it is extremely
bright I I've seen rocket launches
before and the the flame is uh as as
bright as the sun it is quite
extraordinary
um as as it does accelerate and and it
will be rapid four second Free Fall then
it ignites and then if all systems are
working properly it will go
and go where
it will be heading down the South
Atlantic past Portugal racing down
towards Antarctica and first stage will
burn for three minutes eight thousand
miles an hour then it drops away into
the South Atlantic uh while the second
stage takes over uh in the upper
atmosphere accelerating 17 and a half
thousand miles an hour and by then the
rocket will be over Antarctica it will
then Coast reaching an altitude of 550
kilometers and then release when when it
has gone over the bottom of the the
planet up the other side if you like
over Australia that's the point where
the satellites will be released uh into
orbit we hope
I don't know how you're multitasking is
it sounds like you've got a Tana or
update there while you talk to us
probably difficult I guess to hear what
they're saying
it looks like we might be getting
pictures any moment I can just see the
big screen that the crowd are watching
over there and they're certainly being
whooping I'm not sure whether you've got
a better picture I can't see a monster
here it's starting to come let's just
give it let's give it half a second uh
as you say this Burning Bright Light
let's just have a look shall we
now this is an aft camera
um view from the drop so we have it
looks to be a successful ignition of the
stage one engine as we make our way to
space
[Music]
and so Thomas what's happening is this
the the sort of the engine of the rocket
warming up if I can describe it like
that
it's actually ignited so it should be
accelerating uh it's it's hard for me to
see from from here but it does look like
there has been a successful ignition the
engine is fired so that rocket
already at the end of the stage one burn
we're hearing so that rocket is flying
down the South Atlantic uh it is doing
uh really well so it's been burning now
and it's taken it to high altitude so
the second stage will be taking over
um that first stage will drop down uh
into the Atlantic and that's the reason
that they've had to to clear all
shipping from the area because you
certainly wouldn't that wouldn't want
that splashing down if you were in a
boat
nominals so far we've had our pitch up
on the bottom uh on the burn time on the
graphical user interface if you do have
that one off uh we have made it through
Max Q Alpha which is one of the most
stressful physical uh moments for the
rocket
um very comfortably through Max q and
then also through our maximum heat
aerodynamic heat Heating
we have made it through Miko our main
engine cutoff that is our newton-3
engine engine shutdown is reported as
nominal
and if we can go back to our aft camera
varying brake wire is broken
we have stage separation
you may see dropouts in the data during
the flight here that is expected as
we're switching between the different
ground stations that are picking up the
signal from the rocket
um
Thomas we're going to keep listening to
this commentary certainly they said
there would be some days but it does
appear that it's been successful can I
glean that at least yes very much so
that it uh that there's been a good
clean burn as this rocket Powers down
through the Atlantic we're being told
that uh Cosmic girl is already on her
way back here to new Kia of course
that's the advantage it is the ultimate
reusable first stage of a of a rocket
launch that jumbo jet has already taken
off many hundreds of times and here it
comes back to to new key ready to be
reused for the next launch